No matter how you look at it, it's gotta be
a major bummer to be unceremoniously cut from
one of the biggest films of all time.
Late last year, it was announced that 13 Reasons
Why​ star Katherine Langford had been cast
in a small but important role in ​Avengers:
Endgame​, but the talented actress was nowhere
to be found in the final cut of the film.
"That is… shocking.
I'm shocked."
And now we know all the reasons why.
Warning: you're about to hear some major spoilers
for Avengers: Endgame… starting right this
minute.
If you've already seen the film, you know
all too well that Tony Stark makes the ultimate
sacrifice while reducing Thanos and his minions
to so much dust in the wind.
As heart-wrenching as the moment is, it's
also the perfect conclusion to Stark's character
arc.
During Endgame's five-year time jump, we learn
that he's retreated from the public eye and
had a daughter named Morgan Stark with the
love of his life, Pepper Potts.
Realizing that he has a responsibility both
to the universe and to his own beloved family,
Stark heroically offers up his own life so
that the Mad Titan can be defeated once and
for all.
During a recent appearance on MTV's Happy
Sad Confused podcast, co-directors Joe and
Anthony Russo revealed that Katherine Langford
had been cast as an older version of Morgan.
She was supposed to appear to Stark in the
same netherworld where Thanos finds young
Gamora in Avengers: Infinity War.
Does this plot development sound confusing
to you?
If so, the directors wholeheartedly agree…
and that's why Langford's scene ultimately
wound up on the cutting room floor.
As co-director Joe Russo explained:
Even though the audience got to see the emotional
bond between Stark and young Morgan, the directors
realized that the sudden appearance of an
older version of Morgan wouldn't really register
with audiences.
Co-director Anthony Russo admitted:
Even though Langford isn't featured in the
final cut of Avengers: Endgame, there may
be a silver lining to the unfortunate situation:
Obviously, her acting chops impressed Marvel
Studios enough for them to cast her in the
role.
With that in mind, it's entirely possible
that Morgan Stark may return to the MCU in
a future film… although nothing has been
announced yet.
Since Endgame's release, a lot of people have
speculated that the film is setting up the
appearance of the Young Avengers, a superhero
team that's been featured in the pages of
Marvel Comics since 2005.
While the MCU's version of the Young Avengers
would probably differ from the comics, we're
sure a few key players would ultimately make
the leap from the page to the screen.
Chief among these: Cassie Lang, the daughter
of Ant-Man.
"Daddy!"
In the comic books, she becomes the crime-fighter
known as Stature.
And then there's Clint Barton's daughter Lila,
who some viewers think might eventually take
over as Hawkeye.
There's also Harley Keener, Stark's young
buddy from Iron Man 3, who popped up at Stark's
funeral in Avengers: Endgame.
If the Young Avengers are going to figure
prominently in Marvel's Phase 4, why not tap
the daughter of Iron Man to lead them?
Here's hoping Langford was cast in Endgame
with an eye towards the future.
With any luck, the actress will receive a
consolation prize for her abandoned cameo,
and score a major recurring role in history's
biggest-ever film franchise.
Otherwise, yeah, that is a serious bummer…
for Langford, and for us.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more exclusive Looper videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.